hey guys quick video for you today for
believe nation I want your feedback and
want your help so the channel has been
growing really well spectacularly well
almost a half a million views a month
which is awesome in the comments you
guys have our you know I say it all the
time but its fuel for me and I've been
toying around with an idea and I want
your feedback on it let me know what you
think for a while now I really wish that
there was something that that was out
there that allowed people to start their
day motivated excited ready to go to
work you know ready to go and chase
their dream setting the schedule having
an environment that supports you have
talked about a lot on the channel and
and I feel like if there was something
in an entrepreneur's daily routine where
they started off and they they were
watching something that made them think
bigger make them stretch their comfort
zones and gave them some courage and
confidence the willingness to be bold
and I've been wanting that from somebody
for a while and I haven't seen it and
and I'm wondering maybe I should just
create it you know you if you see a
problem you see a need go out and solve
it and I'm wondering if a couple
questions for you one if I should make a
series where it's a morning series I
don't know what time it is something
that you think if it's not in the
morning eat in the morning seven in the
morning where you know over coffee I'm
sharing a clip that inspires me or
something something to kind of make you
think bigger not necessarily sharing out
a strategy not something something you
know how to go out and get new clients
how to here's a marketing strategy for
you but just something to help you think
bigger stretch your comfort zone chase
your dreams either me saying something
or or a clip that I found online that
that inspires me that I want to share
with you and just having that as a as a
as a daily routine as a daily routine of
the video that comes out every morning
that you can sit and grab a coffee with
and start your day with and be inspired
so that's one idea the other one is
having some kind of regular session
where I could hang out with you guys if
it's a you know thursday lunch or
ever it is where i'm online for half an
hour or an hour and just a hangout you
guys ask you questions and I help answer
them for you and help kind of guide you
along your path i'm basically looking
you know is there a way to make things
more of a routine more of a schedule
more but you know you know that you're
going to get this every morning you can
come and get these motivational videos
or every week at a certain time you can
have lunch with me the downside is it
means cutting back on some of the other
videos right so i won't be able to
answer as many of your questions i do
two videos a day and if half of them and
now we're going to be these clips these
inspiring things then i may not be able
to answer as many of your questions so
I'm wrestling with it I'm not convinced
I want to know what you guys think you
guys have been tremendous for me to
leave a comment I you know if you
haven't left a comment for in a video
please leave born on this one because
it's it's going to mean a major a change
to the schedule and kristina is going to
Christine it's gonna kill me because I
keep changing the schedule around but
yeah I you know I really appreciate that
comment please let me know you think and
believe I'll see you soon